I want to start by congratulating you on
since the last time I spoke to you you
have a son Connor jr. congratulations
thank you sorry exciting he's here with
me over over here it begs what's
unbelievable I own burnin
yeah I / yes yes and now here's the
question I have for you I have two
children when the first one was born I
couldn't speak for months afterwards I
was so tired and discombobulated is this
gonna distract you at all from the fight
the birth of your son Connor jr. I have
a beautiful my beautiful girlfriend dee
has been has been amazing and and we
have been a unit with the birth of our
son and it's just it's honestly it's
been seamless um I was a little bit
worried early on to see what you know a
lot of people when they enter a fight
camp they have to move away for eight to
ten weeks or so from the family and I
was wondering maybe I would have to be
one of those people and have to do that
but they my son and my girlfriend they
have been here with me we've been we've
been in our home in here in Las Vegas
and it's been it's been seamless so I'm
very very happy with it and I've got to
bring my son along soon along for this
historic event and I'm very very proud
of that I look forward to going and
making my son proud on August 26th all
right well I'm sure he already is proud
of you but yes a big win would be fun
too
you